heute besuchte verteidigungsminister
hans peter oszko ziehen die
fertigungsanlagen von general dynamics
lenzen steuer gmbh in wien simmering
dort werden die 934 pandorum 105
millionen euro produziert damit
investiert das bundesheer nicht nur in
die sicherheit der soldatinnen und
soldaten sondern sichert auch
österreichische arbeitsplätze so
verteidigungsminister hans peter
diskutiert ich glaube das ist ein
wichtiger aspekt wenn wir vom regionaler
wertschöpfungen der politik sprechen
wenn wir vom arbeitsplatz sicher
sprechen aber auch von
arbeitsplatzschaffung schließen
180 österreichische unternehmen sind am
projekt beteiligt der pandur ist das
meist genutzte fahrzeug in
auslandseinsätzen
er wird vor allem beim liga batterie und
17 in strass und beim jägerbataillon 19
in güssing genutzt
die beschaffung des neuen panda evo wird
uns ermöglichen die aufträge noch
schneller noch geschützter und
trefflicher durchführen zu können